>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME
ON.
>> Tucker: WELL, PRIVILEGE
ISN'T BETO O'ROURKE'S ONLY
PROBLEM.
THERE IS ALSO HIS TASTE IN
ART.
AS A TEENAGER HE BY THE
HACKER NICKNAME PSYCHODELIC
WAR LORD.
HAS HE DROPPED ACID THAT'S A
GOOD QUESTION TO ASK BETO.
WHETHER HE WAS DOING THAT OR
NOT HE DID WRITE A POEM
ABOUT COWS.
TO BE CLEAR BETO IS A POET.
HE IS AN ARTIST AND WE DON'T
WANT TO BE DISRESPECTFUL TO
HIS ART.
WE DON'T WANT TO BOULDER
RISE THIS.
THESE ARE HIS WORDS NOT
OURS.
WE WOULD NOT ADD CAPITAL
LETTERS TO CUMMINGS POEM.
IT'S VULGAR.
IF YOU DON'T WANT TO HEAR IT
CLOSE YOUR EARS.
I HAVE NEAT A BUTT SHINE
RIGHT NOW YOU ARE HOLY OH
SACRED COW I THIRST FOR YOU.
PROVIDE MOUTH BUFF MY BALLS
LOVE THE COW.
LOVE ME, BREATHE MY FEET OF
THE COW HAS RISEN.
END QUOTE.
AUTHOR AND COLUMNIST MARK
STEYN STRUGGLING MIGHTILY TO
KEEP A STRAIGHT FACE
TONIGHT.
MARK, HOW WOULD YOU RATE
BETO O'ROURKE'S POETRY ON A
SCALE OF ONE TO HORRIFYING?
>> OH, COME ON, WE'RE IN
KEATS AND SHELLIE TERRITORY
HERE.
I LOVE THE RHYME.
I LOVE THE METER.
I LOVE THE POETIC SENTIMENT
ABOUT BUFFING WHATEVER
PARTICULAR ASPECT OF BETO --
PERSONALLY I WOULD BE
PRIVILEGED TO BUFF ANY PART
OF BETO BUT THIS COW IS
BEING INVITED TO BUFF THE
ESSENCE OF BETO.
AND THAT IN ITSELF IS A
BEAUTIFUL POETIC SENTIMENT.
AND I LOVE NATE LEARNER,
TOO.
I HAVE TO SAY I THOUGHT THAT
WAS ABSOLUTELY DELIGHTFUL TO
SAY THAT A DIVERSITY AND
IDENTITY MEANS WE HAVE TO
PUT UP LOTS OF BLACK AND GAY
AND MUSLIM AND TRANSGENDER
CANDIDATES SO THEY CAN LOSE
TO THE RICH WHITE GUY.
THAT SEEMS TO BE THEIR
RATIONAL.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Tucker: BUT THAT'S THE
THING I LOVE ABOUT IT THAT'S
WHAT THEY THINK.
THAT'S ACTUALLY THE PLAN.
>> YES.
AND THE THING ABOUT IT IS I
DON'T BELIEVE IN THE CONCEPT
OF WHITE PRIVILEGE.
BUT THESE GUYS DO.
ACTUALLY, IT'S HARD TO GET
ANY MORE WHITE PRIVILEGED
THAN A JUDGE'S BOARDING
SCHOOL SON WHO IS WRITING
BOVINE POETRY OF THE KIND
YOU JUST QUOTED AND IS THE
WORLD'S MOST DEDICATED
MIDDLE AGED SKATEBOARDER.
YOU MENKSED THE OTHER NIGHT,
TUCKER, THAT THEY ARE ALL
HAILING HIM AS THE NEW ROCK
STAR.
AND IN OUR INSANE WORLD,
WHEN IT COMES TO POLITICAL
CANDIDATES, IT SEEMS TO ME
YOU ARE EITHER THE NEW BOY
BAND OR THE NEW HITLER.
INCREASINGLY THERE IS
NOTHING IN BETWEEN.
SO IF YOU ARE TRUMP YOU ARE
THE NEW HITLER AND BETO IS
THE BOY BAND DEJOUR.
ALL BOY BANDS ARE DE JOUR.
SOMETHING POETIC IN BEING IN
A POLITICAL BOY BAND WHEN
YOU ARE PUSHING 50 AND STILL
SKATEBOARDING AROUND LIKE
THE RICH WHITE KID DOING
BOVINE POETRY BACK WHEN YOU
WERE GETTING PICKED UP ON
DWI AND BURGLARY CHARGES.
THIS IS ACTUALLY A PARODY OF
RICH, WHITE PRIVILEGE.
>> Tucker: I WOULD LIKE TO
APPLY THE STANDARDS OF
IDENTITY POLITICS TO THE
PEOPLE WHO ESPOUSE THEM.
AND IF I CAN PASS ONE LAW IT
WOULD BE THAT.
YOU WOULD NOT BE ALLOWED TO
NOMINATE BETO O'ROURKE IN
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY BECAUSE
IT'S CONTRARY TO WHAT YOU
SAY YOU BELIEVE.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
AND IF HE WAS THE -- IF HE
HAD AN R. AFTER HIS NAME HE
WOULD BE GEORGE W. BUSH.
HE WOULD BE THE RICH WHITE
KID FROM TEXAS WITH THE DWI
CHARGE.
>> Tucker: SUCH A GOOD
POINT.
>> ONLY DIFFERENCE HE HAS A
D. AN AFTER HIS NAME INSTEAD
OF AN R.